i can see someone i knew as a child and
immediately recognized them as an adult
or i can see someone who worked at a
store that i used to go to 10 years ago
and see them on the street and recognize
them as that clerk my name is jennifer
jarrett and i'm a super recognizer i
remember just about every face i see i
don't have to have an emotional
attachment to people to remember them
i really started to recognize it when i
went to college i would meet people i
would always remember them and then a
couple of months later i'd be at a party
and people would say oh do you two know
each other and i'd say yes and the other
person would say no so then i sort of
started to learn what was a memorable
encounter and what wasn't
in terms of being a super recognizer so
far i haven't really found any way to
utilize it at my last college reunion my
friends were so excited because you know
everybody worries that they're going to
go to a reunion and not remember who
people are so people were sticking to me
like glue so i could tell everyone who
was in the room
[Music]